hey what are you doing down here lunch
is ready
i'm texting marcus hmm texting
that's the most intimate thing you can
do to a lover with your fingers
other than washing their hair so i
texted marcus and he hasn't texted me
back i can't believe i'm asking this but
can you help me
oh rosie yes i am the perfect person for
this job
okay let's get busy what was his initial
text can't believe i missed you this
much after three hours xo
xo girl marry him where's your right
back
hi hallelujah it's a joke i was
insulting him
you know flirting you think he's mad i
bet he's heartbroken
no no we can fix this we just have to
write a very sweet
very heartfelt text that will jump-start
the conversation
hey baby i don't call people baby you do
now
rosa i know you don't like anyone
wishing you a happy birthday so
crappy day to you it's still too much i
assume you're not doing anything to
celebrate tonight
anyone over the age of six celebrating a
birthday should go to hell so
since you're free i need your help
moving this old miss pac-man machine i
just bought why are you so obsessed with
that game
because it's the sexiest video game ever
she's insatiable
rosa insatiable insane
insatiable anyway i bought this old
machine from a bar and i was hoping
you'd help me move it
you want me to go to a bar mm-hmm you
are obviously trying to get me to go to
a surprise party did marcus put you up
to this
news crazy talking we just need to be
there exactly 9 45 p.m not a minute
earlier
also there's a particular door i want to
enter through
where else is going rosa listen to me
there is no party
just get off my donut already don't lie
to me boyle or you will be eating your
bone marrow custard through a straw
that's exactly how you're supposed to
eat bone marrow
all right there's a party i can't give
you details all i can say is i know you
and i know you'll have a good time
you knew me you'd know i hate surprise
parties so
clearly you don't know me at all what
we're friends
i was building up to call you roro one
of these days that will never happen
in fact you just lost rows of privileges
from now on you can call me diaz or hey
you
come on rosa come on hey you
can't pull him over this close to the
drop site it'll alert the buyer i see we
follow him for a mile
copy that hired your mom enjoying the
new phone you got it for a birthday on
march 16.
dude stop saying random facts to try to
prove you know me that's not what i'm
doing
i'm simply making small talk with my
friend rosa who went skydiving once
enough i'm going to the dumb party but
only because i don't want to hurt marcus
i'm still super mad at you
like how you still super mad at gilmore
girls for how the finale went down
i just want to see laurel i happy and
shut up
yeah see i know you're so well i knew it
was oh
okay before we go in remember you have
to pretend to be surprised
how's this oh my god it's so much worse
than i imagined
the energy was great but the message was
flawed all right let's get this over
with
surprise what's going on i
rented this entire bar so you and i
could celebrate with
no people anywhere near us probably
should have hired a bartender though i
have no idea how to make drinks
this is incredible it's all charles's
idea
i told you i knew you wrote row thank
you
but never call me roro again oh but i
will i've earned this
happy b day row row
hey you guys seen boyle yep he's in a
little ball under his desk
oh no did you watch grimm again last
night you know it gives you nightmares
i'm sad jason died this morning
sorry it's terrible is your front of
yours he was my dog
oh okay so no big deal then no it is to
me but
don't worry i'll find a way to power
through
oh god this is how jason saw the world
wait was this your dog that humped
everything yeah that's how he died
he was going to town in one of my snow
boots and his little heart just gave out
he didn't even finish gross anyway we
have to work a string of b and e's on
4th street
it's time for you to move on that's what
jackson would have wanted jason whatever
little buddy
what are you doing just sealing jason's
collar in airtight
bag so it retains his scent i don't know
how many whips i have left
wow look i know that dog meant a lot to
you so i got you this
it's a dog his name's arlo but you can
call him jason too or whatever
seriously i can't just replace jason
with some other dog
why not all dogs are basically the same
watch this arlo go hump that toy
get away from that that's jason's
look man i've been patient but we have a
case we need to work on
it's time for you to get over it move on
move on
move on jason was part of my family rosa
i loved him his humping was the only
thing that got me through my divorce
seeing him so happy made me believe that
i could be happy one day too
you wouldn't understand this because you
have a motorcycle helmet for a heart
but i need to feel this sadness so the
only thing that i'm moving on from
is you
so i like have a dog now
briefing room now i really don't feel
like having to yell at me anymore
what is this it's a funeral for jason
i'm gonna say a few words
when jason died seven days ago i didn't
give a rat's ass this is your speech
cause i didn't understand why people
care so much about their dumb dogs
until i got a dumb dog myself
i've only had arlo for a day and a half
but if anything happened to him i would
kill everyone in this room and then
myself
very violent eulogy i like it charles
i'm sorry
you don't have to get over it take as
long as you want
scully it's time
what happened how am i dead you saved my
life
died
[Music]
so what do you got your eye on what you
haven't dated anyone since you broke up
with pimento and funerals are a meat
market
sadness is a powerful aphrodisiac no
it's not then how come everyone cries
during sex
i'm already seeing somebody boil how and
just like that things got interesting
and just like that i left hey rosa
are you ready to go streaking what
that's what my dad and i called getting
blonde streaks in your hair
we should do to our ponytails on road
trips you just take a little lemon up
top
and let the sun do the rest we call it
giving each other roadhead you just said
you called it going streaking it had a
couple names
hey speaking of names who's your new
boyfriend
and now we're all sleeping in one room
next to a cow orgy i'd much rather be
hanging out with you
what are you doing boyle you're just
brushing my hair not you becca i was
talking to charles i was just bringing
you some water thanks
mm-hmm so uh are you talking to
is that your mystery hunk babe are you
all right is everything okay yeah it's
fine i'll call you back later
is that a woman's voice it's my sister
wait
she called you babe when my cousin
called me babe you said relatives
shouldn't do that
what's really going on i'm dating a
woman
i'm bi oh that's great
that's great roy i just want you to know
that i totally important i want to talk
about it right now
okay just leave it alone boyle by all
means not
you becca okay i love you
i love you too hey hey
so i didn't say anything about being bi
because i didn't think it was anybody's
business
and i also didn't want anything to
change i get it i'm sorry so nosy
actually felt really good to tell
somebody on the squad finally
i'm glad it was you all right also
now we go back to never talking about my
love life again uh request tonight
is your name ann meredith kim erica
moana i'm glad we got these sweet cams
what is happening with your voice this
is body cam charles
i gotta sound badass in case anybody
watches the footage
compete oh i just smelled soup on the
camp
why do you have soup on a stakeout oh no
crap
oh it's not turning back on do you think
sarge is gonna be mad that i spilled
fun the cam definitely if i say full
like that when you tell them i'm not
going to mispronounce it
not while you're rolling go get yourself
cleaned up
see anything serge not yet don't know
why i didn't go undercover as someone
wearing a scarf
terry hates windchill wait
here's our guy got him crap
i think he made me he's headed toward
the restaurant you follow i'll cover the
back alley
[Music]
charles you're completely naked
you have the right to remain silent you
have the right to an attorney
you